get excited because in this video we're
going to talk about one of the most
important laws in all of science and
that is the law of conservation of
energy you'd be amazed by how much of
the universe we can infer based on the
law of conservation of energy and you'll
be amazed by how many holes you can poke
in science fiction plots based on the
law of conservation of energy let's just
start with the language that you might
typically see and then we'll try to
understand it a little bit deeper
so it tells us that the total energy of
an isolated system is constant
energy is neither created nor destroyed
it can only be transformed from one form
to another or transferred from one
system to another i pretty much
underlined the whole thing because it's
so important
now to understand this let's just think
about the types of energy that we have
studied we have studied things like
kinetic energy which is the energy due
to
an object's motion
we have talked about potential
energy
which you could view as
energy due to an object's position and
that would be the case of mechanical
potential energy if you were to combine
these two types of energy together
they're known as mechanical energy so
let me put a little box around it
that is mechanical
energy
and when you're first learning physics
these are the types of energies that we
focus on but there are other types of
energy there's thermal energy
you have nuclear energy you have
chemical energy and so these aren't the
only forms so when we talk about the law
of conservation of energy things like
kinetic energy could be transformed into
chemical energy but we're not going to
talk about those other types of energies
in this video
so to start to appreciate this let's
first think about how mechanical energy
can be conserved so you can almost view
this as a law of conservation of
mechanical energy but then we're going
to make things a little bit more
complicated and see if we can trip
ourselves up and see if we can somehow
defy the law of conservation of energy
and be very skeptical of anyone who
claims that they can defy the law of the
con of conservation of energy
so let's start with a system that
contains all of the earth and a ball so
let's just call this the earth
earth ball system
earth
ball system and when you're dealing with
the law of conservation of energy it's
important to specify your system and
we're going to assume that it's an
isolated system that it's not
interacting much with other outside
systems things like the sun or whatever
else and so we have i've drawn the earth
here in this kind of grass flat thing
and then let me draw my ball and let's
say my ball is held above the earth just
like that
so while the ball is stationary and
we'll assume that there's no air here so
while the ball is stationary like that
then we have all potential energy we
could call it gravitational potential
energy so it's all and the symbol for
potential energy we tend to use is u and
we could say this is gravitational
potential energy and we could say
there's no kinetic energy
no kinetic energy if we thought about a
broader system if we talk about the
solar system or something like that
then the earth is orbiting around the
sun the sun is orbiting around the
central galaxy but that's why we're
specifying this is the earth ball system
but what would happen if i were to let
go of the ball and especially what is
the energy profile of the ball right as
it touches the ground right over here
and i'm assuming it's just going to hit
the ground and just not bounce in any
way that would complicate things
well in that situation all of a sudden
you have no
no gravitational potential energy
but right as it touches it not when it's
stationary right as it touches it it's
going to have a lot of kinetic energy
so all
all
kinetic energy
and so what we saw what we see here is
that that potential energy all gets
transferred into kinetic energy right as
that ball touches the ground now i know
what you're thinking but what about
right after that moment if that ball
especially if it doesn't bounce if it
just sits there it looks like we have no
energy anymore it looks like energy has
been destroyed so my question to you is
where did that energy go pause the video
and try to think about it
so some of you might say hey once the
ball has just at that rest there well
maybe we found a case where we have
defied the law of conservation of energy
and remember i told you be skeptical if
anyone ever tells you that where the
energy has gone it's actually go it's
been dissipated it has gone into heat it
would have been converted into thermal
energy so the ball and the ground would
actually get that much warmer because
that kinetic energy right as it touches
the ground would be turned into thermal
energy so once again we have not defied
the law of conservation of energy
now another thing you might say is well
okay imagine a world that there is air
so let me draw a bunch of air particles
right over here and we know that if as a
ball falls down it goes through the air
the you can consider that air resistance
some people would call that the friction
duty due to air
well that would slow that ball down so
maybe it would not have as much kinetic
energy when it gets down here and so it
seems like energy would be destroyed in
that situation and once again i would
tell you no the energy has not been
destroyed as the ball falls down it's
going to heat up the ball and the air
around it and so once again that air
resistance that is a dissipative force
it's going to result in the generation
of thermal energy and if we wanted to
write this in terms of equations there's
a couple of ways to write this
we could write if we're just writing the
law of conservation of mechanical energy
and we're not talking about dissipative
forces we could say that the initial
kinetic energy plus the initial
potential energy
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to your final
kinetic energy
your final kinetic energy plus your
final potential energy
now another way to write this exact same
thing is to say
that the change in kinetic energy
plus
the change in potential energy is going
to be equal to zero assuming we don't
have any dissipative forces and assuming
that we're not converting into some of
these other forms of energy like
chemical energy or thermal energy but if
you wanted to include dissipative forces
dissipative forces do something called
non-conservative work they do actually
negative work because the force of say
friction is always acting opposite in
the direction of motion
so to factor that in we could rewrite
these equations
we could write that your initial kinetic
energy
plus your initial potential energy
plus any work done by non-conservative
forces this would be like air resistance
or friction and this would be negative
right over here if we're talking about
say friction
that is going to be equal to your final
kinetic energy
plus your final potential energy or this
one right over here
we could write your change
change in kinetic energy
plus
change in potential energy
is going to be equal to the work done by
dissipative forces and remember if we're
talking about friction dissipative
forces this right over here is going to
be
negative
another way that you could have thought
about this is we could have put in
thermal energy we could say that our
change in kinetic energy plus our change
in potential energy plus our change in
thermal energy is going to be equal to
zero
or you can include the work done by a
dissipative force and so for example if
you saw a situation where your total
change in mechanical energy right over
here was negative you're not defying the
law of conservation of energy it's not
that energy was destroyed it's that you
had this negative
work done by that dissipated by those
dissipated forces and where did that
energy go it gets converted to thermal
energy so let's do a couple of other
examples just to appreciate this
so
let's do a earth pendulum system here
so here that's the earth
and then i have some type of
tower
and let's say i have a pendulum here
i have a pendulum and at the low point
the ball just goes right over there and
then it goes back
up to that point
and let's say the difference in height
between this point right over here and
this point where it is right over there
it is it is equal to h
so and let's say this is the highest
point that the the end of the pendulum
will get to
so at this point we are at maximum
potential energy and right as it's about
to change direction we have no kinetic
energy it's going to be stationary for
just a moment
but then the pendulum is going to swing
back and when it gets right over here
all of that potential energy is going to
be converted to kinetic energy assuming
we don't have any dissipative forces
like friction air resistance and then
all that kinetic energy gets converted
back into potential energy
another example that we could look at
that would complicate this a little bit
more is to think about
an earth spring ball system so that's
the earth and let's say there's a spring
right over here
and we have a ball that starts
stationary so up here it's all potential
energy gravitational potential energy so
all gravitational potential energy
assuming we have no air resistance we
let go
right before it touches the spring when
we have maximum velocity
here it is going to be all
kinetic energy
all kinetic energy but then it's going
to compress the spring and assuming we
don't have any thermal energy generated
you actually will always in the real
world have some thermal energy generated
but if the spring gets compressed at
some point the ball is over here
well now you have some of that energy
that's been converted into spring
potential energy or sometimes it's
called elastic potential energy because
by virtue of compressing that spring
this thing is going to rebound and it
can be converted back into kinetic
energy and or gravitational potential
energy